welcome back to new rockstars I'm Erik
Bosse and Jumanji the next level was a
holiday hit that unlike stuff with
lightsabers and hair balls it actually
lifts everyone happy I had a chance to
rewatch this film and now notice all the
interesting Easter eggs and callbacks to
earlier films of the franchise homage to
classic adventure films and just of
intrigue dukester this bonkers brain
into conspiracy theory mode I'm going to
break this all down its boiler warning
if you have not seen the movie yet and
thanks to Jumanji the next love it for
sponsor in this breakdown get Jumanji
the next level today on blu-ray DVD or
digital film opens on a tropical Jumanji
esque paradise but actually it's a photo
taken by Bethany for her group text
thread first time we saw her in the
previous films she was taking a selfie
now she's more interested in the world
around her than her self fridge where
he's a necklace with the number 94 this
is a nod to the number 1 by Dwayne the
rock Johnson back in his football days
Spencer bails on their holiday hang out
instead stays home but his mom and his
grandpa
Eddie Danny DeVito joining the cast when
we first see Eddie he's high up
struggling to change a light bulb
setting up his task as Ming at the end
of the film triumphantly reaching up to
the Sun with the Falcon Joule and he
gets visited by his longtime buddy Milo
Danny Glover they used to co-manage to
the diner that became Nora's for Bethany
Martha and fridge meat we learn at the
end of the film that Nora is Nora
Shepard aka Aunt Nora
Phoebe new earths character from the
original Jumanji film so they all look
for Spencer then all of them except
Bethany gets sucked into the game with
him Martha is once again Ruby roundhouse
karen gillan but now Eddie is dr. brave
Stone the rock Milo is Mouse Finbar
Kevin Hart and fridge is Shirley Oberon
Jack Black this character was
immediately eaten by a hippo in the
first film now they managed to avoid the
hippo but it gets eaten by a huge snake
instead Rhys Darby returns as the non
playable character Nigel this time in a
plane and the letter becomes this
cutscene explaining the new level in the
new big bad Jurgen the brutal played by
Rory mechanic a the Hound from Game of
Thrones they show how he stole the
Falcon jewel which gave fertility to its
avian province a plot similar to Indiana
Jones and the Temple of Doom the Sun
Cara stones at Indy must retrieved to
restore the fortune to its native
community the backdrop is that of that
Valley in Hawaii those also uses the
location for Islam Nublar and Jurassic
Park Nigel drops them off in the desert
dunes where there's this dramatic music
sting
[Music]
this is a nod to the theme from Lawrence
of Arabia famous for its similar
landscape photography
and they find these rusty dune buggies
and they run into an ostrich which
attacks Eddie actually if you remember
Alan Parrish faced off against a similar
pissed-off bird in the original film
this appearance of an ostrich could also
be a nod to an episode of the Jumanji
animated series in which aunt Nora
transforms into an ostrich the ostrich
comes back with a whole herd and Milo
confirms they travel in herds they do
move in herds meanwhile Bethany finds
Alex Colin Hanks his character from the
first film and we learned that he named
his daughter Bethany as a way to thank
Bethany and the others for saving him
meanwhile the players are seeking the
flame that leads to the fruit in the
town it's here where they run into
Jurgen he feeds pieces of his brother to
his hyenas and they also find the cat
burgler Ming Fleetfoot Aquafina
Spencer's avatar now they also find the
Jumanji tree berry which Martha accesses
with some lara croft style swinging
acrobatics in the glowing water causes
her in fridge to switch briefly and
switch now test out the ruby rat house
avatar by just jumping and kicking
you know like noobs do when they're
learning how to play fighter games now
one of my favorite things about this
sequel is the way it really plays with
the non playable character humor like
Eddie confronts a group of them and this
guy only knows how to save one scripted
response and move along nothing to see
here
what'd you say I said keep walking pal
nothing to see here beat it what'd you
say I said beat it get out of here
what'd you say a common move on a really
annoying NPC so next they flee these
mandrels on this elaborate rope bridge
system and one point they call the
monkeys which makes this a bit
reminiscent of the monkeys from the 90s
film and the fact that remember Peter
turns into one of these when he cheats
at one point martha swings on a rope but
then she swings back towards the
eighth's it's actually something like
that moment when alan swung back toward
the lion in the first movie but Eddie
ends up cutting the rope to make them
all fall he's using these same exact
move that Indiana Jones used in the
Temple of Doom then Nick Jonas returns
as z-plane McDonough Alex's avatar with
his horse cyclone which is actually a
playable character played by Bethany and
they find another glowing stream that
they use to switch back to their
original avatars with Eddie now is Ming
and Milo as the horse oh wow welcome to
the jungle comes back as they emerge in
the water and then as they all
infiltrate Zef Myers strongholds alex
rescues Milo in a barn booby trapped
with very similar floor dark
triggers as the temple in Raiders of the
Lost Ark and as Ming sneaks into the
vault she's lowered in very similarly to
Ethan hunts the mission impossible as
all hell breaks loose in the common room
fridge it plays peter frampton's 'baby i
loved way the song at martha used to
dance fights in the previous film
Spencer fights near again he gets about
control and then Eddie and Milo
deliberate into the Sun save Jumanji to
complete the level now Milo who revealed
to Eddie that he was sick with eternal
illness decides to stay in the game as
cyclone the horse you know not to get to
San Junipero here but like is this a way
to live eternal life in this movie
universe is Milo's safe as cyclone the
horse in the game's loading screen does
he have to play all the levels until the
game eventually beats him in he dies if
this is a way to go once all these
characters get old and sick shouldn't
they just like totally plug back into
the game anyway Spencer shows Eddie how
to play his video games it's actually
the same game that we first see him
playing in the previous film and then
they're all back at Nora's Eddie decides
to return to the diner drop some
smouldering intensity on Nora and then
there's this post title scene showing
lamorne Morris for new girl as a heating
guy in the basement we activates the
game causes ostriches to charge into the
real world
just like how in the original film
elements from the game spilled into our
world so does this mean that for the
next Jumanji film that will probably
happen
the avatars from the game world could
meet and interact separately with their
human counterparts and without players
controlling them with the rock Jack
Black Kevin Hart Karen Gillan Aquafina
just be mindless non playable characters
that Spencer the others have to like
Corral teach to act human and then
defeat the real enemy which would be the
Jumanji game itself comment down below
with your thoughts on this theory and
again thanks did you want to the next
level for sponsoring this breakdown here
the movie today on blu-ray DVD or
digital follow me at EA boss followed
new rock starts and subscribe to new
rock searcher breakdowns of everything
you love thanks for watching bye
[Music]